welcome to trash Tuesday late night
Edition does everyone want chicken
tenders yeah that's just got us yeah
get them what I got
okay yes so here's what's happening just
to fill you guys in what you have missed
since we last Saw Carlos has turned
violent Carlos it is crazy Carlos I
don't know if you remember the Storm Out
episode but we are about to have a redo
I'm gonna say this Carlos
not great Precision or aim or happier
thing thank God thank God he throws like
a girl I'm trying to actually hit that
you did hit her you were trying to hit
us I was trying to hit Annie and Esther
did get in the way yes
we'll settle out of court I hope Esther
thank you for taking the bullet for me
you're welcome we know it was an
accident
I will still she was trying to dive out
of the way
and Carlos's aim was so bad I got her
so that's like the story of my life what
happened is we've been record we
recorded an episode right and then we
just kind of sat here because we're all
losers with no plans on Saturday night I
just have plans and
we're like we may as well roll because
this is just a there's a Vibe there's a
Vibe and it did get violent though the
vibe is like no one wants to go home and
see which is that's sad no I was waiting
for y'all to leave so you could start
or stop
hair and you're gone you probably sniff
our chairs
I would sniff kalila's chair I would
wear your around my neck like if there
was a way to sort of like crystallize it
or put it inside like a capsule
can I just tell you the best part is
that Pete has like an actual family and
it's saying for this he was like we got
demons Pete's like this show is not
going well it's two minutes and my
children are crying they're hungry
they're asleep they need me to tuck them
in I just before we move forward I need
confirmation and please don't be mad at
me I'm just I got
it is it ordered everyone
preparing your order good stuff is in
the works
Joe is sponsored by betterhelp as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched three million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp help.com
trash Tuesday this is urgent literally
this weekend I'm going to be in San
Francisco Portland and Seattle we added
a second show in San Francisco so if you
couldn't get tickets the first time
they're there I can't wait to see you
guys I love the Pacific Northwest I'm
going to drink so much coffee you can
get tickets at Esther onice.com and
don't forget when you're doing all your
holiday travel listen to my pleasure
wherever you listen to audio podcasts
hey soggies man am I full Thanksgiving
is over thank god
um you can see me in Michigan December
1st and also December 2nd and 3rd in
Grand Rapids I'll be in Las Vegas Nevada
at Wise Guys December 30th and 31st ring
in the new year with me it's going to be
amazing I'll be at Burbank for one night
only in January 7th and then you can
also see me the end of January in
Wisconsin I will be in Florida in
February and March and I will be in
Canada in April get your tickets at
annieleterman.com shows also you guys
I'm so excited please uh enjoy this show
and then go over and see Annie wood it
releases every Tuesday at noon Pacific
time it's been so fun and so amazing I'm
so glad for you guys to enjoy it just go
to youtube.com Annie Letterman
[Music]
so we're hungry but the food is on the
way and that's what's important I put on
lipstick because I was trying to fool
the audience into thinking this was a
different day I was so funny she
literally went Kim came back with
lipstick and he's on yeah so this is my
attempt at um a whole brand new wardrobe
I have no clue nothing underneath oh I
have a bad friend sweatshirt which I
love this is so soft really and you're
wearing Kyle's vest Kyle and I [ __ ]
things got crazy we [ __ ] I blew him
and he liked it
and he liked it that's so sad we're
giving a [ __ ] yeah and he liked it
the boy liked what I did too this with
my mouth have you ever been with a guy
and him visibly not like what you're
doing or not yet like you can tell he
does not enjoying what you're doing well
the only example that comes to mind
immediately is when I was having sex
with a guy and I said you're so hot and
he didn't respond well not all not
everyone's a talker in bed I get that
are you dude if if you said to a guy
you're so hot and he didn't say you're
hot too back that's the worst that sucks
when I hooked up with my my hot New
Zealand audience member I wake up with
an audience member it was the only time
this one time he was so hot wait can I
yeah I got I wish I had his old he used
to send me these pictures like they were
he was just so hot but then we like he
was so hot you would die he was an
island a boy he was so hot but he I was
on stage and I couldn't believe it like
I started doing crowd work with him I
was like oh my God like I literally like
oh my God you're so hot and um I had
gotten sunburned I had like a like Red
Lobster sunburn okay and I was like I
saw him and his other friend was there
who was hot and I was like oh my God it
was like the worst did you guys know
what the worst part about having a
sunburn is and they were like what I was
like
um when two guys from New Zealand are
[ __ ]
and rubbing on it it was just like crazy
I was like joking like I was gonna
[ __ ] because he was so hot like it
was just and then I started talking to
him I found he was from New Zealand I
was like am I imagining this and then
um I didn't want to hook up with him and
then he kept it I talked about it I
think on the Ashley episode but he like
he damned it was like just I'm only in
town for another night please yes yes
let me like sit on your face or like my
face and I was like okay but he I was
like you're so I kept being like you're
so hot you're hot and he wouldn't like
say it back I was like I'm just so sorry
you have to like even though he came for
me but I was like you have to equal it
out like a little bit and he was like he
had he goes here I have a compliment for
you that I can't say this from many
girls he goes you look really good naked
he's like a lot of people don't look
he's like you look better naked I think
I'm better partially clothed fully naked
I'm not sure
like no I'm saying don't believe it I I
prove it
like she was about to I was about to
would you ever have sex with two guys at
once no I like made out with guys at the
same time like we just were like [ __ ]
up in college highly recommend but they
I told you the story I think they
started making eye contact like my one
friend was like I'm done and he started
just doing the soundtrack he was like
I'll do the music while we I was like
this is my boyfriend you're just gonna
watch my boyfriend back he's like I'm
not looking like what is going on and he
so he had a crush on me so he was trying
to hook up with me and then so he was
like all right I guess this is my shot
and then my boyfriend at the time was so
gay he was like a that kind
and um he just let's just say we'll call
him a PA
talk [ __ ]
do your job
Carlos I no Carlos you're a bad boy
today you're gonna get honestly Carlos
it's it's kind of working for me I know
we've been joking this whole time but I
would it's gonna sing a wet spot look
look my pussy's gushing really out thank
you do you not like my camel toe I like
your camel toe I think I have a really
pretty camel I don't have as much like
camel
wait Carlos dominate us come on dominate
me Daddy do it Daddy I want another Pony
dominate me
y'all are gonna get your food soon
you'll be fine y'all are just on the
edge right we all get our food we're
repulsed by him immediately it's just
that we're hungry that's what it is
right it's like a guy who's full of calm
like he has all the poison in him once
you extract the poison these are normal
human again at least he has no comments
did you get okay on last week's episode
which was three hours ago did you
actually get hard when Kyla was touching
it was like it was happening it was
getting there because she was touching
my my balls and all that stuff I can get
you there daddy he's gifted she's like
gifted the way she figures even herself
I'm like I don't think I finger myself
with as beautiful as a of a I don't put
fingers in myself
um when I masturbate no it's like
performative if like there's a guy on a
FaceTime like if Carlos calls me then
I'm like yeah I'll I'll put stuff inside
me what do you want in here but besides
that if it's just me getting off by
myself it's like no it's two two seconds
like and then but do you ever try to do
like do you ever try to every once in a
while I try to really like just like
spoil myself you know I told Jason
masturbate on money right when I was
broke I used to take my money with ones
okay it was so sad it was one dollar
bills some quarters some pennies you get
the little Mark do you make it rain on
yourself like are you make it hail
can I I'm gonna project an idea on two
that I have it's like you're like a
you're like a [ __ ] nurse like I'm so
[ __ ] you're like uh yeah sexual not
like why'd you say it like we didn't
realize I saw you fingered Carlos's
[ __ ] you're like a sexual nurse like
there's something very medical about the
way you approach it like it's very
professional like I just read a textbook
on it yeah can I say something about sex
I am I'm very reluctant to have it with
um
a lot of people but if I'm if I'm down
for you I'm telling you like there that
is the one place I know I will excel
wasn't it the worst when you [ __ ]
someone and you're not fully giving you
don't yeah you feel like the like half
in sex that's nothing that is the worst
experience they're like self-conscious
sex or you're not fully like right and
also it's like for me it's like it's not
even like about coming and there's so
many ways that I find sex and like
physical anything pleasurable it's just
nice to like make out and do whatever
it's all fun for me I kind of want to go
to like a tantra weekend too like I want
them together do you want to what is a
tantro weekend I don't you go they I
don't know I think they it's like scary
because the people leading it usually
try to [ __ ] you I think I think it turns
into like oh I think so too but like I
don't know this is so horrible what is
one to one
they did yeah but I think it just like
helps you get like you like Center and I
don't know do the sting stuff will you
look it up will you look up to see if
there's a there is the Tantra Institute
in Colorado where you can take Tantra
speed date
you hike before you come that's that's
you have to pay can you is there like a
synopsis is there like a website that we
can look at like what their pitch is for
a tantric weekend
by the way have you guys seen that right
what
I don't think it's a weekend like they
do weekends they do weekends classes
workshops should we have like a tantra
instructor yes
um have you guys seen how Travis Barker
and Kourtney Kardashian have been
talking about edging yeah I love edging
what can you what is it for me yeah
that's that's literally like well of
course she just tried [ __ ] weed for
the first time yeah I'm learning I I
didn't have I think he's getting so
close to coming and then stopping
yourself and then building for me that's
what I understand edging to be it's like
like when a guy is going down on me and
like let's play let's say let's suppose
like we both plan to Edge or we both
agreed to it's like right before we come
we stop
and then we do it again and right before
we come we stopped is this something
that you did with Bobby no Bobby was
edging her for like six years
Bobby was a was a a fun fun lover in the
beginning when we were still really into
each other but it was fun Bobby is like
a fun a fun so fun to have some fun [ __ ]
a fun fun [ __ ] I love a fun [ __ ] I think
that that just means that you're fun
uh maybe but he makes things a little
interesting because he plays along yeah
do you [ __ ] Bobby
in life oh my God can we all [ __ ] Bobby
no oh no okay sorry I genuinely feel
that I am the most repulsive like he
looks at me and he feels like he's
looking into a mirror
it's like the Danny DeVito drawing of
mine
but wait so edging to me does not sound
fun that's like it just sounds pain
you're a little impatient yeah if I'm
allowed to say because yeah because
don't
okay what do they say their edging is no
that's why that's what it is
but like
isn't the thought of getting all
jived up and then not going like
horrible that's kind of the tease of it
it's like because it's like you can just
[ __ ] come every day if you want right
I think that's for me it's so easy for
me not to brag but it is it's always
been easy for me to come so for me it
took so long now it is but God damn did
it take a long time do you have to think
of really [ __ ] up things to come yeah
no I could come in my sleep not touching
myself like I have wet dreams and I come
in my sleep I have some mushrooms too
what this is not normal what like right
now staring at you like this I can make
myself come yeah you can mentally do it
you can do it yeah you can do it you
want me to come there's a giggling
situation
wait fist yourself real quick wait do we
do the saber for the live yeah kalila
comes on demand
that's what edging is she's learned to
Edge yeah
I can wait till November 17th tickets at
moment.com trash Tuesday we gotta do no
parents on this one yeah no parents are
invited sorry guys their like IP address
like is there a way oh I know how to do
it I just won't pay for them to get it
and they won't pay and then they won't
go
this is weird I literally like look up
to Carlos's dad like he's like a what's
he look like yeah Mexican
he is so weird he's like a hard worker
and like smart as [ __ ] he just I like
love Carlos's dad like is there a Vibe
like no I'm just kidding you guys
whatever Vibe like I feel like we'd be
best friends have you not met no meeting
no she's never met no I Met Your Dad
very briefly at your wedding and he
escaped oh God at your wedding that is
so weird let's talk about Carlos's
wedding tonight oh my God wedding night
were you when you did you have vows or
um I did have vows yeah I'm just right
um was it emotional Esther did you
believe it was really like a true love
honestly this is so sad but like I was
Carlos and I were so checked out from
our friendship during that period of
time because she really like
didn't let him have friends kind of I
would say is that no that's very fair to
say she didn't yeah I think she was
insecure and so she didn't like a lot of
the girls I was friends with but to also
to not put it on her as like you are the
kind of guy though you could put it on
her no no no you are the kind of guy I
feel like [ __ ] that [ __ ] when you get a
girlfriend you like but I feel like
that's everyone's thing yeah because I
feel like no you don't do that now are
you like [ __ ] whipped yeah but it's
more because I was like 26 and I was
like wow a hot girl is into me this is
crazy like because in your 20s you're a
[ __ ] loser in L.A because you know
I'm hair
did you guys hear that I wish I might
gone wait no
this is a smart theory that you talk
about a lot you should share it just
that when I was younger I was like but
applies to all guys in their 20s in La
yeah when you're younger in La you're
just like you're a [ __ ] loser
basically because everyone has more
money than you everyone is like all like
the 40 year old guys in La dress like
they're your age when you're 26. they
like skateboarding and throw your girl
they used to have all the nicer versions
of the [ __ ] you have so why wouldn't all
the girls go towards them yeah people
are so [ __ ] original it's crazy yeah
so when I met a girl who's like super
hot and like cool I was like just all
about it because it was like something
you don't just get every day how long
were you together before I got married
two years oh wow okay yeah and I'll bet
again I saw Benji the other day yeah
yeah oh yeah we all hung out with Benji
me and you
what back in the day or no do we hang
out together no me and you hung out with
Benji at the concert like two weeks ago
he and I went Benji I'm I go I'm okay
with this having happened but I'm just
curious if I did something you did just
we were friends and then you just
randomly unfollowed me and he went no I
was just and I go okay I'm just curious
because I like to hear what people get
mad at me about because it's always
something so funny that I like will
usually stand by it's usually a funny
thing I said in public
but I like but I just was curious and he
was like get offered up no info But Then
followed me so now we follow each other
again wait so he unfollowed you and
years ago and he didn't tell you why no
I just noticed that I want to go I guess
we're not friends like it wasn't like a
because we weren't that close we were
really like close in the beginning and
then he we got in a fight with you yeah
or we got in a fight with him and then
it was happening we got in a fight
because of him yeah he did do a fun
thing but then so I just didn't really
hang out with him either but he I was
actually with him when I drew that Danny
DeVito drawing
did I ever tell you that I was at his
apartment
I think it might have been the day that
we surprised you
wow now I'm upset now you're triggered
but
um I remember Benji going don't draw
you're never going to make any money off
of that like write jokes and I was like
no I feel like I'm on to a good drawing
here and then I've made so much money
off of that it's like way more viral
than any joke I've ever made
it's not funny wow what was that I just
felt like I was like I'll just ask him
but he didn't have a good answer have
you ever asked someone that and gotten a
good answer
um well like I feel like like when Akash
came on he was like oh I didn't like you
because of this and then with Jeremiah
like Jeremiah I was always wondering why
he didn't have me on stand up on the
spot I was like how come you never had
me on stand up on his body goes no Annie
I had you on stamp on the spot and you
went well he goes you went up and then
you went does La ever have stand-up
shows like do we ever get to do what our
job is what is all these weird stuff
like I just like talk [ __ ] on his show
to him and pretty much said I never
wanted to do it he's like I just thought
you didn't want to do it because you
told me to my face you didn't want to do
it and I was like see I'm the opposite
I've never told him I don't want to do
it and he's never asked me but I don't
want to do it I like doing it now though
and it's actually something I like to do
but it was when I was like you remember
when you needed spots so bad yeah you're
like I have a new joke I gotta work this
out so I would be so disappointed when I
would show up and it would be like you
know it's actually a storytelling show
and I'm like I have a [ __ ] new joke I
want to try yes I'd like desperate time
yeah so that's what it was but I like
doing it now now it's fun it's like oh
okay I can maybe come up with a new joke
like in the early days like when you're
asked to do a show and then you show up
and they're like it's a theme yeah you
can only do jokes about driving a car
like oh my god what the hell I'm on the
car show
Esther I gotta say I really like the
denim vest it's such a good look are you
guys no dead too I'm not even kidding
wow you look like you built something
for us today
what can you build
um do you have Legos or duplos what are
duplo's I can build a case against Annie
um duplos are like the really big
versions of Legos that babies use so
they don't choke on them that's what I
played with
yeah are we still keeping chokeables
away from you at this point
no grapes no shrimp she almost ate
olives by the way you guys missed this
it wasn't on camera Carlos oh yeah this
is so fun Carlos brought the girls okay
not the guy left the guy alone brought
the ladies two bags of Olives he goes
they look hungry we were so hungry and
and he was so nice I have something for
you and I was like so insulted I was
like I do I exist I got no olives then
they both start to open them as Esther's
realizing that they have been open for
probably all this time
kalila pulls out one that looks like it
like it looks like it has like
tonsillitis you know when you look in
and your urilla has like yeah it looked
like strep throat it was just white
marks all over it oh I was like are they
supposed to have white spots on them
because she's new to olives she could
have very easily eaten that Olive that
makes me gag it smelled just fine yeah
she would have been fine and we got Air1
on the way girls how far is it though
don't do your placate the girl's voice
we're running late girls if he gets into
this mode where he treats us like we're
the Spice Girls and he's our manager and
I'm Posh
um
uh it's being picked up by oh that's
like my cat's name
oh is she bringing it here yeah
oh Mike walks in that's
the vibe that's the start of my life are
we on mushrooms
like is this mushrooms like what is
happening we definitely have a
drug-induced like or a silliness induced
drug feeling I think that Pete put
something in the vents to
brainwash us into doing a second episode
today whoa we were like because I do
feel high there's carbon monoxide
poisoning or something like what is
happening wait now I'm telling something
so funny about what Esther did earlier
what we tried to talk about like the
dates for things and she goes I'm not
comfortable or ready to speak of the
dates and then we got her ass in the
chair to do another episode to go from
that to this is kind of amazing well I
just meant I wasn't ready to talk
because I don't know what I don't know
my schedule but I did not expect that we
would be doing a second night I'm very
tired but somehow this is fun and I have
nothing better to do we should shoot at
night sometimes it's fun goodbye I'm
down it's night time here in Los Angeles
I never know I think who we are at night
is completely different like for me like
this is my Witching Hour like if like if
you catch me at midnight and we've all
facetimed at midnight this is like
everything spills out the good juicy
stuff the juicy the juices let's see
what we can find being appropriate dig
suck everyone's dick right now Carlos
pull it out including your speed sorry
why are you doing this to me just please
God don't do this to me of all the
things to do not this to me
this is kalila I'll suck
when he gets here look I can't even tell
the difference right now
Chucky this is evil Chucky boy
does not know what they're walking is in
her [ __ ] oh my God gladly Light Me Up
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
unfortunately life does not come with a
user manual and it should because it's
really hard and I need therapy and I
need a lot of help and if it did I'd
like to be the author because how rich
would you be how rich would you be if
you were the author of the owner's
manual but we don't have that so we
gotta go to therapy you guys navigating
any of life's challenges can make you
feel unsure whether it's a career change
or a new relationship or becoming a
parent therapists are trained to help
you figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and learn productive coping
skills
and honestly it's like it's cold out the
holidays are around the corner like this
is a time where I need a little extra
help I need to talk to someone who's
trained and knows how to deal with a
crazy person's feelings yeah it's
cuffing season some of us aren't cuffed
she's on cuffed she needs therapy and
you're an uncuffed Gem and some people
are over cuffed and they also need
therapy and some people are just right
cuffed and you also need therapy you
just need therapy at the world's guide
user as the world's largest therapy
service better help has Match 3 million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's affordable just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist and if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhealth.com trash Tuesday that's
betterhelp
help.com trash Tuesday
Annie how do you get your day started I
get my day started I get up all right I
give Randy a little tongue kiss I put on
his leash and then I go into the kitchen
and I make some athletic greens I shake
them up it's easy I put a packet in or
put in a scoop put in my Water Shake It
Up take my dog for a walk and chug my
salad for the day baby I'm back home and
I've already had all my salad for the
entire day
with one delicious scoop of athletic
greens you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right this
special blend of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
and aging all of the things it tastes so
good too it tastes great it's easy you
don't have to chew do you not want to
chew I wake up with a sore jaw sometimes
I don't have to chew and I've got all of
my vitamins and it's lifestyle friendly
whether you eat keto paleo vegan dairy
free or gluten-free it costs you less
than three dollars a day you're
investing in your health and it's
cheaper than your cold brew habit and
everybody loves it okay athletic greens
have over 7 1 000 five-star reviews
they're recommended by professional
athletes and trusted by Leading Health
experts such as Tim Ferris and Michael
Gervais and it just eliminates any kind
of like guesswork
um about what I'm gonna eat that day to
meet my body's needs I just have one
scoop cold water my Rochester and then
that's it I don't have to worry about it
for the rest of the day it's delicious
and right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into the flu and cold season
it's just one scoop in a cup of water
every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health and to make
it easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com Tuesday again that's
athleticgreens.com Tuesday to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
thank you
do you think that you'll use condoms now
that you're back on the market
good question probably not I haven't she
said she's all in are you kidding me
like my favorite Kink is like telling
them to come inside me and them me like
preemptively telling them if I tell you
to come inside me resist and then really
try to get wow really [ __ ] up but no
that is a weird thing that I do and I
know like you know rain down on me
probably like rain down in me baby but I
think it's something biological in me
where I find it really hot to be
creampied of course it's the greatest
feeling but that's edging so that's part
of my edging thing it's like I tell a
guy we're gonna Edge you are not
absolutely not allowed to come inside me
but I'm gonna beg for it with all my
might I literally like pull them in and
I try to like fight them it's just keep
them staying there and they're like
[ __ ] me off like that is uh bucking
her off yeah
but I'm really strong right so I just
like clinch my thighs you know that one
time I've had to take Julie several
times
the first time that I was at your
Peloton instructor so you can no it's a
it's a new contraceptive a morning after
it's a new like morning after pill that
has like yeah yeah they were they
emailed us yeah uh-oh available at
Walmart
um and so is your outfit
[Laughter]
wait wait so the first time I had sex
with a guy I won't say who but it was
really embarrassing because I was like
oh yeah we don't need to use the condom
and then he was like no we do oh my god
when you tell a guy you're down and not
use a condom and then they insist it is
there it is like the saddest moment girl
I know it is so I was his mom though I'd
be so proud how about okay I was dating
a guy
we broke up for like
a week okay I didn't [ __ ] anyone else
okay we go to bang we like I was like
meet me at this this bar and let's [ __ ]
in the bathroom I was like horny so we
bet he brings a condom he brings a
condom I was after one week after one
week I was like you think I'm like
hoeing that bad no he had maybe he was
hoeing that bad yeah that has to be it
right yeah I can I tell you a really
terrible story a guy told me he was
um he was married to a woman with 10
years had two kids with her and um he
went to a different state to like just a
boy strip somewhere and he got chlamydia
on that trip sleeping with another woman
he came home
um but he didn't know he had chlamydia
yet and he had sex with his wife the
next day he had he started like burning
having the symptoms and now he's like oh
[ __ ] I already [ __ ] my wife so what he
did is he he knew his wife was um
dealing with some like weight issues and
he said here here is this new pill
because he was a a an instructor this
guy is a mastermind he was a uh Jim what
do you call it a trainer at that time so
he was like oh this new pill on the
market it it's supposed to guarantee
like rapid weight loss and so he preyed
on the fact that she really wanted to
lose weight because she had just had
children and it was antibiotics or the
medication for chlamydia he was like you
have to take it this twice a day for
like this week and it's supposed to like
cause like rapid fat loss
that and it worked it worked okay that
is kind of Genius but I would never
trust anyone even if it was my own
husband to give me a medication I didn't
know exactly what it was or what it was
for if Carlos gave me that Carlos gives
you drugs oh wait lost drugs yeah I
guess
to wait never mind check the pocket of
your vest baby girl got something in
there for you
huh
um um wow yeah let's see and this is
like stories that I've always been a
recipient of and now I like I think it's
[ __ ] with my idea of like man like I
have a really hard time trusting like I
am somebody that always checks phones
and checks all of your gadgets well
that's something it's like it is like I
cannot act like is it bad like is it bad
it's like I just give people their
privacy just because like I want to get
easier than you will I want to get there
but when I first start dating them like
with Bobby I stop I don't think it's
been five years in right I'm over
feeling like it's that right because you
do want to know and some people have
burned you and it's it's okay but I feel
like like I was with a friend of mine
and his wife was like looking at his
phone and like to take a picture or
whatever and he was like nice try trying
to get my password for me I'm like your
wife doesn't have your password that to
me is weird I I agree yeah Todd could
have that can go through anything of
mine ever at all times like I get off on
being that close with my boyfriend you
know yes so that's why like when I have
found out well my guys my boyfriends are
cheating me I'm like
I thought we were like together in this
like it's like us together okay so let
me pose a scenario for you let's suppose
I start seeing a guy I really like him
we really like each other we're maybe
not in an exclusive relationship yet but
we're getting there we're getting to
that point of feeling like okay like
this is I'm we're gonna put it out to
the world that we're together right but
um so everything is there except the
label should
should I have access to his phone at
that point
like let's say this has been going on a
year
wait you're in a relationship if you're
just like I'm sorry I'm starting to lose
it I need to share something really
honest I zoned out because I realized
that the chicken tenders are coming and
we don't have ketchup
I feel like every order comes with a no
no it says it at the bottom of the order
like it has like a little thing that
says ketchup wow
I don't know if I clicked it that means
that you didn't you're fine [ __ ] you
don't need all that [ __ ] sauce do
your job no wait is there Pete do you
guys have ketchup in the office there is
this underlying thing where Carlos
thinks his job is harder than ours and
it's like so
I really need to catch up I'm freaking
out you're not freaking out what about
your lipstick does it taste like ketchup
[ __ ] juice in your mouth barbecue sauce
Carlos can you tell us a ETA
on your phone we want to watch Kyla deep
throat a chicken tender
and we want to do it now made its
arrival by 805. what time is it 7 36
right now oh my God what's the estimated
arrival
what oh
no that's not acceptable
show me what show me I need to see it
Master needs to change time with her own
brain
hold on
hey do you know who's so cool not Carlos
right now he's hot bothered
I am like now the biggest fan of Julia
fox saying yes warn me always but I
think we always were yes but her tick
tocks have taken it to such a new level
like she's so just spits reality and
facts and like honesty and I feel like
most celebrities don't really do that
well they kind of can't because a lot of
celebrities are in the like agreement
I'm gonna keep secrets right but wait
wait what is that is that that sounds
like yeah but not that sounds like uh
conspiracy theory like you're getting
giving me babies blood Vibes with that
no I didn't mean it like that but I just
mean like it's like there's that you
can't like
like if you want to be in people have to
trust that you're not going to be like
spilling all their [ __ ]
um but she's not spilling people's [ __ ]
she's just like
speaking out about
how [ __ ] up like
having to be a single mom is and how
like Society doesn't help that or like
capitalism is bad for people don't no
are you gonna keep going or yeah I had
another one but now I can't remember
kaleila help I think the last one she
talked about is the difference between
um Democrats and Republicans that was
like yesterday's post but I will say
this about Julia Fox I think I always
liked her everyone wanted to paint her
as this like one-dimensional like arm
piece of Kanye but the moment I saw her
I was like that that is a bad [ __ ] also
she's had like she's just an artist I
see her as like a full-blown artist
she's like a combination of controlled
and sloppy that I don't even know how to
explain like she's so like sloppy and
like oh and I mean in a compliment like
I don't even like so like free free yeah
no I think Sloppy is a compliment
actually yeah I like it like she's not
like
she's out there but she doesn't seem
self-conscious yeah
I was shocked she's only 32.
she's cool yeah she is very cool yeah is
she really short I feel like she's short
Carlos
she does misogynist no it's not mistake
excuse Carlos I mean
wait what were you about to show us
why didn't I like her big D why didn't
you like her y'all don't even know her
but misogyny make y'all choose size with
women and actually have to prove
themselves as a cool girl before y'all
sign off on them who the [ __ ] is y'all
you know then we could think about
having a deeper conversation while y'all
always feel like y'all have to not like
somebody
yes yes that is so real and such a real
part of our culture and I feel like
I know I'm certainly guilty of it it's
like a woman pops on the scene and it
just you instantly like judge them and
not like just what she said and it's
like why do we do that and how do you
like grow out of it though like yeah I
think you just find your own piece and
you're not so like anxious when you're
like you I don't know you find like
maybe it's like a thing people in their
20s do well also the way we all talk to
each other about things where do you
stand on this as if we have to
immediately pick a side my mind changes
like every day every day every day it's
it's like staying neutral is is not
fun or you know what I mean is it's like
that's another way you can Edge is like
to look at someone and to just see them
with curiosity rather than judgment if
you're first if you meet someone or see
someone on the screen or anybody and
your first instinct is to judge rather
than be curious about them like you have
to really dig deep like she's saying
like that's so interesting to I want to
like apply that to everyone just be care
I think I am but like that I never have
put it into words like that just be
curious and not yeah what are you about
like get to know them like you know
immediately like we're in this like we
have to place them in a box in our head
because like the indecision of not
knowing exactly where that person falls
is like uncomfortable but I will say
like you said it's like
you you have to either like them or
dislike them and you can't be neutral
but like most of the time if people are
speaking up and being interesting it's
not because they have a neutral take so
it's almost like just to be an a voice
and entertainment you have to you have
to pick a side but also it's like you
can just observe someone picking aside
and not like I mean I'm friends with
people that drastically disagree with me
on things like we take completely
different stances on things and that
doesn't make me like consider us friends
but I think in this show at least we've
been really fair with Julia Fox I think
we've all I loved that bed yeah I feel
like she's a like ideal trash Tuesday
Universe a thousand I feel like she's a
true slug like a true adaptation of like
a slug I have to post that Pete that one
you made for me where I like spread my
remember I wore green and then he put
Julia fox in my green screen Julia Fox
into my underwear
can I can I
um talk about like green room secrets
and comedy you know having been with
Bobby for as long as I was and going on
the road with him or being at the comedy
store it seems like the most favorite
like pastime of comics is to
who do we hate and let's talk [ __ ] about
other comics and I every room like
without fail if I'm in the green room I
and I told Bobby this I was like doesn't
he get tiring to just every like it's a
new comic you're talking to and where
everyone's just [ __ ] on each other
about how much you hate it's so fun when
you find the same person but yeah it is
in the past but isn't that like just
such a common thing like that's all I
ever heard in like backstage or in the
green green room was like people talking
[ __ ] behind people's back
I can't believe this is coming up
because I have such a thing to share
that is so hard to talk about because it
makes me so uncomfortable
I think I told you this yesterday Carlos
but maybe I didn't because I think I was
so embarrassed
someone who is a fan of mine someone who
follows me someone who
like likes my posts and has responded to
my stories like oh this is very friendly
accidentally
sent me my own story oh that's so
amazing and sent a rude ass [ __ ]
comment about it it's because you're
doing well baby can I see it it love
this for you Esther tell me why because
they're jealous you're doing well I love
when people [ __ ] out themselves in
this way because you don't even have to
do any work
but the thing that is so weird about it
is it's not even like a friend it's like
a fan it's like what are you what why
why are you my fan then like what are
you it's like it's blowing my mind it's
like really disturb me I'll show you I I
and I wish I hadn't but I just wrote
back yikes because I was in such a sh I
was like shaking I was like this is so
weird what are they right back they
didn't write back
I had the last word
um and it was yikes
I love being a fly in the wall though
and listening to Comics talk about each
other because
um my favorite part was like Esther say
for example like this one girl would
just go off
kill me if my career becomes like if if
you have to compare my career to Esther
like just kill me and then I saw Esther
start to soar like way yeah and that
thing that voice like that Esther always
was soaring past her that's the thing
it's like that girl I know who you're
talking about always bullied like
literally so jealous and you and she
like such a tryhard and you
it just came to you so okay it's so I it
was this story I posted of me standing
over my two vibrators in my Columbine
book and for some reason it says it's
giving tragic nerdy Victoria Secret pink
Vibes which I'm like that's not even
cool yeah but it's it's obvious what it
was like it is you know it's very clear
what happened here like she's meant to
send this to a friend and make fun of me
and it you guys like why why why are you
my fan and like I'm not it's only been
like we're friends like you have to deal
with me like I just like I really sat
with me all day it doesn't sound bad
but you know what it it's a snarky mean
Poe it's a are you sure let me see it
again Annie
it's giving tragic it's giving tragic
nerdy Victoria's Secret pink Vibes and
she sent the story
it's like are you sure she didn't mean
to send that to you yes
don't take this away from me I'm the
victim it doesn't maybe she's just
Delilah I I I'm partial I think Annie
there's there's a she didn't reply to my
story she sent the story and said oh I
see what you're saying she didn't reply
it's giving tragic nerdy Victoria's
Secret pink which is lame now bye well
you know her better so I I I don't know
her
I just don't know I what I just thought
it was gonna be so mean and it's not
that mean
it's but I'm just trying to be funny
but she sent the story she didn't reply
to it that's yeah but but maybe it's not
if she maybe well maybe if she hears
this she can clarify but and maybe
you're right but also co-host we have a
fourth
but also it did I have to say it made me
reflect on myself and it made me think
like
well yeah why do I ever like make fun of
people's posts or [ __ ] like why am I
ever snarky about what other people do
like that is my [ __ ] Pro because I
turned against this girl I'm like [ __ ]
you and so then I had to of course look
within and it's like why do we do this
why do people in The Green Room just get
together and talk [ __ ] about each other
it's like you're literally talking about
famous comedians who are living out
their dreams getting paid to do what
they love why do they have to like take
others down while they're doing it like
I I will I don't know by the way I'm not
just a fly on the wall like I fully
participate no I think we're all guilty
of it listen I am good at [ __ ] talking
it is such a bummer when people tell
other people I'm like you miss the
Cadence but I think for you though like
the [ __ ] talking is almost like there
it's almost like uh it's for sport and
out of like there is like a goodness
yeah
that's like a different level I will say
okay there was okay so I had a friend of
mine one of my friend dumpies okay was
like wait what's a friend she dumped me
which is fine it's and we're fine but
it's like but she like when I met her we
were at a festival and it was like we
fell in love because we hated the same
people and we were like crying laughing
like it was like this epic level of like
I guess it's a way of having fun we just
were like laughing and every such a good
time and then eventually our
relationship crumbled because
that's the foundation of the Friendship
then it's not a good yeah but like
prognosis but like you know like I can
make with like you just tease each other
like if it's teasing it's fine it's like
my dad teases your dad teases like yeah
there's a light like and I think there
is uh there is an option for you to take
that lighter than you're taking it but
if you're taking it that way there's a
lesson to learn and taking it that way
too but I just when I heard it it's kind
of like
I don't know like
that does that have to be an insult what
she said you posted a picture of vibers
and Columbine
yeah I I almost I have to kind of decide
with I don't want to take this away from
you Esther but it doesn't seem as like
like malicious like I thought it was
going to be like this stupid [ __ ] think
she's something or whatever like that's
like
they strung together
and also
so and also Victoria's Secret pink I
guess is bad but also all those bad
things become ironically cool and funny
like maybe that's an inside joke with
her friend or something yeah I guess so
I guess it's like we're we're all
projecting our own thing onto it and for
me I'm projecting on to it that that's
like a snarky thing that like I would
say maybe I'll not hit you in a way at a
certain time that maybe in a week would
not hit you that way that's also true
that's also true
I do feel like it came in at a baby at a
level so they wanna like if people are
hating us we're doing great too it's
like there's not always like
you can't have everyone no and that's
true that's something no one hates on me
I am a beloved figure on the internet
how dare you
don't take this away from me don't you
[ __ ] cut this out either I am beloved
I am beloved and you guys [ __ ] you
also are too that's the thing I'm
[ __ ] in in real life actually I feel
like you could be giving good advice
right now on how the [ __ ] you deal with
that [ __ ]
um I don't know just cut your wrists
nightly and hope you bleed to death and
never wake up what do you think
emo Coco she's gonna write a poem about
you about Jew about you
how about you no I I don't it makes me
miserable I hate it I cry so sad and it
hurts my feelings but it's like what
like what can I do and it's like you
know better like it's like of course we
know better to not let the comments
bother us but it's [ __ ] crazy
like a victim of it because it's just
like whatever we're just like saying
stuff on a [ __ ] platform and it's all
nonsense but it's like and even like me
doing bad friends it's like Bobby called
and said please please please I'm like I
just got off a plane I'm Delirious can I
sleep I am not gonna make it please just
do it it's like yeah I'm gonna do the
favor it's like I didn't [ __ ] say hey
guys please have me on no no I already
know it's gonna be like not well
received but it's like no I'm gonna do
this because you're not I'm not beholden
to you I'm beholden to Bobby like he's
my friend yeah if he needs me I'm gonna
say yes and I've said this before it's
like so embarrassing to Bobby the people
that are like so defensive I'm like this
50 year old man like his friend his
ex-girlfriend from the amical breakup
nothing bad happening like needing to
create all these things but go back try
to put like their conspiracy theory but
it's not about her and Bobby it's about
these people and what they're projecting
and what someone did to them it's like
that is what helps me lately it's like
it's all our own thing that we put out
there and even Anne Hathaway recently
did an interview where she was like I
won the Oscar and like America hated me
and I just had to like shut myself out
and deal with it but she was like a
punching bag and all this [ __ ] yeah and
I'm like whoa that's interesting like
you could literally win an Oscar have
all your dreams come true and like
and still deal with internet hey and now
she's beloved again do you know what I
mean it's like but I think anyone this
is what I tell myself lately it's like
if 10 people like you 10 people are
gonna hate you so if you want 100 people
to like you Esther a hundred other
people are gonna hate you and the more
like the more exposure we all get the
more that Park Rose the more they both
grow yeah yeah it's and it's crazy it's
like our job is just to talk like
khalila's been doing this for so much
longer than us too it's like
what I tried to do for so long is to
almost like uh minimize myself on social
media post less but I'm like have your
discourse about me have it all and I'm
gonna outwardly say it hurts me it makes
me sad but it's like there's no point in
pretending to be strong about it
pretending that it doesn't affect me it
sucks it sucks mean thing I get it sucks
and you're like wait am I this person
they say I am because like it makes you
like really second guess like like I
think I have a good heart I think that
I'm like generally like a solid human
being so it makes you kind of like
second guess like all of these there's
like what are you guys seeing like what
are you but how could it not because
have you guys ever seen like those
videos where they there's like two
plants and they say bad things to one
plant and they say good things to the
other and like the good ones Between Two
Ferns and then Zach elephant is gross
but it's crazy like the good the one
that gets the loving words like grows
healthily as the other one doesn't but
the thing is we this is like a weird
exercise for us like that's specific in
this thing and kalila is the one in the
hot seat right now but it's like yeah
for all of us like we're not like immune
to this house coming for all of us
there's gonna be all of that for us but
it's like this is like an exercise for
us to be like we have to give ourselves
the thing that we're not getting you
know it's like we cannot control this
external there's no reason for this to
be happening you know it's like it's
nonsense it's just something that caught
a wave or whatever and it's like so it's
just we gotta give ourselves the good
things and not like measure ourselves up
against like what
these [ __ ] Ding Dongs also like I
like to think like picture someone in
your life who you know that is like
awesome and killing it like some or
someone you look up to
oh just as a happy person do you think
that person is like on Reddit like
writing bad things about like no they're
happy they're not doing it so the people
who are doing it I think are really not
doing well and that makes sense because
our country is [ __ ] up and so like it
sucks that that's their coping mechanism
but also maybe to them since they don't
really know us and maybe they realize
they don't know us are they're just
having fun in the green room talking
[ __ ] thinking that they're just having
like a good time and not even like I
have this guy that um right maybe they
don't think it would ever affect well I
have this guy that's been following me
forever and I always make fun of him on
the don't bore me thing because he is so
annoying like he will like he is so
critical and annoying and so like
demanding of things and I remember his
name because of how much he's annoyed me
throughout my career and so on this
interactive show I have like it's like
we're talking like I'm talking to him
directly who is it do I know him uh Ron
Phelps he's like nice he goes I'm nobody
why do you know me he's like how do you
know me I'm like I'm like I love Iran
like I know it's all coming it's so
[ __ ] annoying he's like I can't
believe you know me he's like this is so
weird like he doesn't even know like he
thinks he's speaking out into this void
you know yeah but it's like there's a
different thing happening now because
there's this whole subculture of like
comedian haters right that are like and
they're getting like so many views and
it's becoming their money to find things
wrong with you specifically right now I
mean literally with you and it's like
yeah
I put it this way if you're if you're
like video compilation of me like puts
food on your table like I'm okay with
that she gave she let people steal her
[ __ ] equipment
right so you're still all you're doing
is stealing her it's like throwing my
name and as is part of your algorithm
like feeds your family and gets you the
meal that you want [ __ ] use it who
gives a [ __ ] it is kind of amazing how
like you're pretty popular no you're
profitable baby
you're a meal ticket for all of us I I
am yeah but I but it is a weird thing
because it's like you know like you are
like an evolved person so you know to
not like and I'm speaking for myself too
it's like I know better than to let
Comics comments like but it but it's
still you're just like oh
it does but you know what
you just
you have two options well you know you
could be a plant that dies or a plant
that keeps growing so you just kind of
power through yeah you know take it day
by day you know what sucks like with all
of like any Scandal or anything we've
had or whatever like sometimes people
will bring those things up to me on the
road and stuff but since you don't
really go on the road that much like you
don't get like the love like everyone's
always like tell us to Uncle I love them
like talk loud no one has ever in a
million years said a negative thing
about you to me so it's like it's just
like
you don't see it like you're at a
disadvantage because you don't
then us I think because you don't get to
like really really meet them that much
right right that's true so should we go
on the road yes yeah [ __ ] I mean let's
do a comedy store main room or something
let's definitely do that let's do a real
[ __ ] show yeah we could okay it'd be
easy yeah let's do it everyone asks me
all the time I go I don't know we all
these all of us there's three [ __ ] we
got like [ __ ] so many different
schedules I'm like Esther's like in a
movie she's in the ocean
food is here bear one break air one
break
[Music]
we're back from Air1 breaks
better we're very mad oh I feel like a
food coma
coming over me no I feel good I feel
great give me some [ __ ] liquid death
recently I literally said I think I said
this to you even like
I'm I don't want to move forward anymore
I want to go backwards maybe you're on a
good train right now you want to move
forward I want to go to the base sir no
we want to get no Esther
we want marble countertops okay we want
a big we want man but I can just buy
those sticky plastic things you put over
the and make fake marble countertops and
be really happy you're just gonna be
richer than your you want I guess yeah
it's happening it's always been
happening I want to go to the basement
I'm like I never got to have that era of
my life where I just smoked weed in my
parents basement and I feel like most
people get that why don't you build a
basement and you're beautiful exactly I
think your entire home your the first
home you build from scratch will be just
a basement like an entire basement I
love how you guys are manifesting that
but
it's not manifesting and it's like
happening it's just like it's a role it
doesn't stop
will even make you a bed inside like a
giant dog crate
for Jacob oh my God someone brought me a
Jacob bracelet for you
guys keep making this bracelets do we
have kleenexes in the studio
for the Jewish people I my whoever made
um that bracelet for me that said
molested yeah I need another one because
mine broke off
um it ripped off and while I was out
somewhere and I didn't notice it and I
lost it can someone make me another
Millet yes okay what okay are we selling
the same Amy
wait hold on I'll find out her yeah I
need it I did tell her that much I was
like I do want to let you know that we
didn't have this idea already I was
seriously thinking today
like will there ever be a day where I
[ __ ]
get in person face to face with my high
school ex this is so crazy or something
about this imagine if you let this go
what could come in its place what
beautiful things could come in its place
if you just let this go but it's not
taking up so much room that it was just
thinking about it
but like what does he look like now have
you checked she doesn't know I can't
really talk about what he looks like
without like being offensive
oh see okay
Carlos you are literally anti-semitic
and you're energizing all of
anti-Semitism if I can do that and rise
up people that says a lot about me and
that's exactly Sarah Silverman's coming
for you Carlos no seriously you're going
to [ __ ] Hall you know what no you
know what I'm gonna great this is great
well guess what George hands no I went
to the Holocaust Museum when I was a kid
that doesn't wait that doesn't matter no
no no okay you cheered you cheered I'm
Jewish I'm quarter Joe okay so now I
there's the one of the world-class
Holocaust museums it happens to be in
Skokie Illinois where I'm from we have
the highest population of Jews would you
escape from the museum
and they have this new program which I
know you know that's what you meant by
your ex-boyfriend if you were gonna be
offensive no it's because he's very
overweight oh
Okay so
we all get sad so uh the worst thing it
can be they have this program that like
to in order to carry on the stories of
people who survive the Holocaust you
have to eat as much as you can they have
Holograms of Holocaust Survivors that's
a lot yeah my mom told me about this the
other day I know so I have seen it and
you're like Mom just put money in my
account I don't care about your silly
Jew story
yeah
and so I got to go and watch this and
watch this woman tell this story and she
talked a lot about how when they were
first freed from it and survived who
freed them
Abraham Lincoln Queen Esther no that was
the other Jewish people Mr King but
um they didn't talk about the Holocaust
they never spoke about it because it was
this traumatic thing like no it's not
like you so they have a lot in common
with Mel Gibson it's not like you could
deny the Holocaust it's not like you
show up to America free and you're like
guess what happened it's like you just
[ __ ] survive yeah and it wasn't until
the KKK decided to do a rally um like a
famous March in Skokie and they the KKK
chose Skokie because Skokie had the
highest population of Jewish people and
Holocaust Survivors and it was then when
all the people who had survived the
Holocaust were like what like got scared
and were like oh we can't stay quiet we
have to speak up and tell our story and
that's when like that's how they started
to speak up and tell so
because you said something so [ __ ]
mean about Jewish people now I'm going
to tell you a really sad thing so this
woman told a story about when I say mean
about Jewish oh do not play this game
you said I don't want to say something
offensive about my ex-boyfriendness and
I thought oh is it because he looks
super Jewish okay so you were making a
joke no but I wasn't no but then you no
if we play back the tapes then I was
like you're in what since then help me
so this woman said that she was her and
her mother were taken away to
that like trains and they were in a line
and they said adults go here children go
here and the mother stayed with her
daughter in the line and the daughter
said Mom no you're supposed to go in
that line oh my God it's just crying now
making me feel bad then her mom was sent
to death not the way you take it you
just feel the feeling and don't make it
about yourself
and like I'm not mad at you I'm just
saying like these are the [ __ ]
stories and I know there's horrible
things going on in Iran and everywhere
and [ __ ] I just learned about North
Korea like and I know that's the what
happened however many years ago and with
the Holocaust isn't the worst problem in
the world right now but it is still
really serious and like when I hear that
story when I think about how Jewish
cemeteries are vandalized like where my
grandparents are buried like people go
to the cemetery and spray paint [ __ ] and
Jewish Nazi symbols it's like
no Kanye you can't [ __ ] say that [ __ ]
because look what happened and like
again I don't that's that
there now I cry oh Kanye maybe we lost
your your subscribe subscription but
we're okay with that you can unsub
talking directly to Kanye
on that note
on on that note I want to add to well
yes on that note
um I just I didn't just learn about
um nuclear testing in the Marshall
Islands obviously like I watched a
documentary and I was much younger
um the US tested a lot of like nuclear
bombs in the Marshall Islands and a lot
of the population developed these like
horrible deformities they have these
thing called the some of these babies
were called like jellyfish babies
because they were literally like they
were so is that why your neck is Annie
Annie like and it's so sad but that is
the history of the word bikini like the
the bikini that we wear was named after
the bombing of the Bikini Atoll and the
Marshall Islands and for a way for the
US to sort of sell this idea that the
bombings were necessary they put women
in these two pieces like they were like
using sex to sell do you guys know you
don't know about the bombings in one
piece Island right
so is Bikini canceled Speedo Island is a
Bikini Kill yeah I think Bikini Kill
might have been might have been that
might have been what they were yeah I
think so she wants me to be like her do
you remember me
so good bikini girl is a band a girl
band that's so good
she wants me to be like her give a sad
history yeah your turn sad history
you were molested let's go there I know
also over it once I heard once I started
doing don't bore my realize my
molestation's pretty light that's what I
said I would say mine is pretty light at
any time I opened the door for people to
tell me their stories I'm like oh didn't
have it as bad holy [ __ ] I'm okay yeah
and then you know what also I was I was
watching an Eckhart toll
um or totally I don't know how you say
it um
a video where he was talking about
not having trauma is a trauma for people
people like not having anything bad
happen to them becomes the thing that
happened to them actually George Kimmel
that's what I always say about him
something happened to him you don't
think so no nothing happened to him a
haircut that when he had assaulted by a
barber like I think he is like a perfect
example of someone that if it wasn't for
the podcast world I would probably never
connect with because he is he just lived
the way he describes his childhood which
is so like cherished but wasn't he in
like a religious cult but he loved it so
they granted him a certain level but
fear of God is scary is that trauma and
is that I don't think he sees it that
way so when he had any like a little bit
of Freedom he was like I'm gonna try I'm
gonna really do all the drugs I've got
to take over this world what podcast
but that's exactly it it's like nuclear
bombs of podcasts everywhere
podcast Island podcast Island not having
a trauma is a trauma everyone's all
[ __ ] up but it's all good oh yeah
um sad tale a sad tale tell us a saddest
tale I've cried on the show I've told
sad Tales incredible yeah
um I barely cried I don't cry a lot
no then someone tried to steal the
Thunder up with a bikini yep no no no no
no no no
he goes you're trying to make you can
cry on demand I will oh my God he's he's
calling me a crisis actor
she's hogged David Hogg
I did when I was in a death and dying
class I don't know what I was took a
death and dying class in college that's
like why I the first time I moved back
to Philly I took a death and dying class
because I and I moved back to Philly
because I was like oh my God I want to
be near my parents I start to freak out
it was actually a really good I almost
went into gerontology because of it
wanted to do hospice work and stuff it
was really like a cool class whoa but
um what did you learn
I don't [ __ ] remember but um but it
was good it was beautiful it was just
like different like cultures how they
look at death and stuff but so
um and then we looked at like the
different like the denial of death all
this stuff okay anyway
there was a girl in my class we went
around the first day and we were talking
about like our experiences with death
and like what you know how it's touched
us and this girl I swear she was last
everyone like said their thing my
grandma
my dog you know oh my like a sibling or
something you're like oh my God it's so
bad my cousin like oh
this girl goes all right I'm just gonna
come out with it
I went to Columbine and I was sick that
day and all my like three of my friends
died oh [ __ ] Are you serious am I crazy
this was in your class yeah and you know
what she was wearing
Victoria's Secret pink oh [ __ ] you no
but that really happened is that crazy
wait that is is that insane she was sick
that day she missed that day so she was
like survivors and her friends died two
of her friends died or three I don't
remember exactly but did she talk more
about like did you get not really I mean
nobody really wanted to like cry yeah
you know when I always feel like a
special with people who are coming it's
like whatever they want to share I'm
like honored that they're like willing
to like open up but I never want to push
or pry that reminds me of this uh moth
podcast episode that I just listened to
um can you imagine like that I was on
and she like forgot to tell us as on the
moth
um no but this this man recounts a story
about his gay Awakening basically
um he was uh I think in elementary or
like a middle he was a teacher and
um he was he hadn't come out to anybody
yet but he called like a hotline and he
was like he was like
I didn't know where he was like just he
was just like in a crisis in his life
like I like you know tell me where the
closest gay bar is and the person like
actually gave him like this place to go
Carlos where is the closest gay bar
that's like in Milwaukee somewhere he
was like oh go to like Celebi or
whatever
so he goes to this bar
and this gay bar and next to him is this
man who he remembers so vividly as just
being like smelling so deliciously like
chocolate
he was like and then
um everything that's good
that sounds good to me it's it's a
thrill for him
to be in this place for the first time
he sees this man who is so attractive to
him he looks at he Head to Toes him he's
like I like the way he's I like his
style I like his smell I like his boots
and he was like maybe if I sort of like
mirror this and dress like this you know
I can you know kind of come into myself
a little bit more come into the gay man
that I have
um and so on his way out
um
um someone talks to him he he like
mentioned the the hot guy he was like oh
like who's he like he's my type and the
guy's like oh yeah he's E.T he's like
what's E.T he goes That's everyone's
type so this man that smelled like
chocolate that he just put on this
pedestal was everyone's type he was just
hot hot
fast forward or after that experience he
starts buying the same boots he starts
really mirroring this man because he's
like this is the gay guy I want to be
it's like the salients right with
mycelines as well yes and so
um then one day he's in class and he
turns on the news for his class to watch
and
um there is
um he sees a man that's familiar to him
on screen and he was like he tells this
whole class he's like oh my God I know
that guy followed by shots of police
bringing down like Vats and barrels down
the stairs and then
followed up by well it's Milwaukee so
yeah yeah the person basically saying
like
the person on the screen was Jeffrey
Dahmer and he has just been caught for
dismembering and killing and eating and
preserving
wait because that is why I wear those
Dahmer glasses please so Jeffrey Dahmer
was like a hot guy so I mean to this man
yeah he got all those guys to go home
with them but you just said he was
everyone's type like yeah I think so
that is freaky and the reason he smelled
like chocolate is because he was working
at a chocolate factory like a chocolate
plant or something like that okay so
like everyone else during the day yeah
have you been to Buffalo by the way they
have a Cheerio Factory near the Buffalo
helium no and it smells so good
[Laughter]
podcasts and credits
but I find it interesting that you can
look up to someone in that way and be
like this is who I want to be and that
person be like one of the most famous
serial killers you know because image is
so like you could be anything inside
whatever image you are like it doesn't
matter like that's so interesting yeah
that was good that we'd all watched the
Dahmer thing and like knew about it and
you
you gotta still except I said Milwaukee
you got it before I was about to go like
I was about when you said Milwaukee I
was about to do an anti-interruption and
be like are we done with Milwaukee these
murder I'm like Milwaukee what's going
on with you guys and any Interruption
Doral complete but that was really and
he told a story really really well the
build up was so good what is the moth
I've never heard of that there's people
really stories yeah oh my God yeah it's
really great
that's weird to not know what it is yeah
I would imagine you'd be like Risk and
moth or like storytelling shows no my
boyfriend once told me my ex-boyfriend I
went back to visit my ex-boyfriend once
I decided that
um I had gone through a breakup and then
um I was really like longing for love I
was kind of like oh where's my place
whatever
and my friend
was like we just started talking about
our exes and she was like well maybe
that one guy is like was always supposed
to be a guy was this guy in college that
I dated who I really love very much my
family loved him and I'd always kind of
like put him on this pedestal and I went
back
um
to New Mexico and I like was like ready
to like be with him you know
and it's so crazy like it's just so out
of nowhere but in my head it's like
you know my friend and I have like set
up this thing where like this is my
person and I have to go get him and we
go and I um
we go and we're like at a nightclub or
something I don't remember what we were
doing but it was like I was he was like
oh I gotta go get my weed for my car and
I was like oh let me come with you I was
like just trying to get him alone you
know and then like get to his car we're
like sit in his car and smoking weed and
like talking and this was like
15 years after we had dated you know and
I'm like
I don't know if I like leaned in for a
kiss or something and he was just like
what are you doing he was like hi nice
to meet you like I haven't seen you in a
while girl like even though we had like
stayed friends but not like that close
but he was just like whoa what the hell
and um and in my head I was like come on
it's like me and he's like yeah but
it's you but also it's like been so long
you know and in my head I was like we're
gonna have this thing you know and he um
he told me two stories like we hung out
for the weekend and we didn't we didn't
um banging and it was like kind of sweet
and like a clue no kissing though no we
kissed the whole thing was like kind of
weird because
it we could have not done it but it was
like I just I didn't bang it it was like
right after that stuff had happened to
me in high school so when I first
started dating him I was a freshman so I
didn't [ __ ] him because I was like
really traumatized by the the court
stuff with my teacher so I like really
wanted to [ __ ] him because it was like
and I was like so confident in my body
now and like I was just like oh it'll be
like you know this thing that we never
did or whatever I bet he really liked
you we loved each other yeah no I mean
like even then like I think that's
actually a good sign when someone wants
to slow down and I really appreciate
that out of a guy like there is a guy
who's
back back then who was really really
really sweet very attractive very kind I
wanted to jump his bones immediately but
the first thing he said to me was like
Hey I really like you like can we take
this slow and I could not have like
appreciated it more yeah he's like I'm
really I don't want to have like sex
immediately like I just like loved it I
love the safety of him saying that I
love the safety there was no rush or
awkwardness I really really liked it it
made me it made me want to jump his
bones even more yeah but did you because
I did no I didn't I really was just like
I wish I had been more respectful of the
time thing because
I I felt like a rush because I was like
I just knew he was gonna like end up was
I was like I just feel like this is like
our last shot like because he was his
whole point was like he's like look I'm
seeing this girl we're not exclusive I'm
not she's not my person you know that
sounds so familiar he's like she's not
my person but he's like I just feel like
it's not like the timing is not good
like he's just like it just like doesn't
feel right right now and I was like come
on like it's like
we just like loved each other so much
you know so I was just like come on and
he was like I know and then we
eventually did end up everything like
fell into place because he was like I
was just so proud of him you know like
it's 15 years later and he has like he
had built this house he like would show
me around he built this like
this um
like sun like a star looking room like
it's like it was had like a glass
ceiling and we're like sitting in this
placey building just like so hot and
like he was one of those people that it
was very much like the notebook but it
was also like he like represented
something so special for me because he
really like healed a lot of my like hurt
from high school and that thing that
happened and he was always so like
loving and supportive of my artwork and
stuff like he just was like a good
person for me and I always kind of liked
the way I reflected off of him you know
it always made me feel really good
so we're like in this room and we're
like looking up at the stars and I'm
like are we really not gonna [ __ ]
bang when you did finally bang like did
it live up it was like good and special
but then he was like really kind of like
he was like a little ghosty afterwards
it kind of hurt my feelings but I also
understand that it was like I had to
look at it from his perspective like he
was just living his life and I just
popped back in like hey let's like pick
up where we left off 15 years ago and I
really like I said to him I was like
look I like I understand that you like
feel like this isn't the right time I
was like but you are gonna get married
and have kids like you are a cat you are
like this is like I just don't I feel
like this is like our only shot and he's
like yeah I guess you're right you know
wow and so it was like you know and then
but he told me two things the reason I
thought about this and it was nice and
it was like romantic and stuff but it
was like I was like I wanted it to be
something
and but it couldn't be that thing like
there was actually not a reality of it
you know and so he said two things of me
I was like too much one was the moth
story and one was a article he had read
but he was like telling me the story
about the from the moth and it was about
this this couple that had dated I think
they were had an age difference or
something and they had dated and maybe
like lived overseas together something
like where like there was a couple that
had dated and
um it was like the girl had red hair
and I might I'm going to totally be
butchering this but I can get the gist
of the story um they ended up like
breaking up because they loved each
other but they broke up because like the
timing wasn't right or whatever and then
they went on their way and then um
and then he was like
they like ran into each other again and
this like little red-headed girl that
came up and was like
was like hey are you oh the woman had
let had had broken up with the guy to
like let him free because he was like
too young Todd not gonna happen
um let him go she's like it's just not
the right timing like this person needs
to continue living his life so then he
runs into her again or she runs into him
again and he's like married with a kid
and the little girl comes up and looks
just like his daughter comes up to her
look and looks just like the mom or
something and goes like
they called her him her his angel or
something there was like something where
it was like the kid was thanking the
woman for like letting this guy go
because like the kid would never been
born but he's like telling me these
stories that are like take a hand [ __ ]
you know that are like hey let's like
let this go you know
and then so that was like cute that was
like a cute story I was like okay that's
fine and then also he told me this story
about he read on a in uh
um Cheryl strayan has a I think I might
have talked about it on here but like
with uh she had a column where you would
ask her a question she would give you
advice and these people were asking
whether or not they should have kids and
she was talking about ghost ships and
it's like in your life you cast all
these goats ghost ships off like whether
you want to like
um when you make a decision in your life
you cast off the other decisions go ship
and she's like you can admire that like
if you have kids you have to cast off
the Ghost Ship of you and your husband
just like being able to travel all the
time and not having kids and having that
life and you can admire that ghost ship
from afar but you can never live that
that's never going to be yours and he's
like telling me this thing and I was
like oh I feel like
like you're kind of like one of my ghost
ships and he's like yeah
duh and he was like because he was like
do you think you could ever like live
here and be with me and I was like No
And then I realized I was like asking
him to like promise me this thing that
like could never happen sometimes that
you really do need that though it's like
you really kind of have to let the
record play all the way till the end
it's like it's a I've been in those
situations where it's like you know the
circumstances are never going to align
like it's that it's a ghost ship that he
said but you have to almost like see it
through or else you're gonna like beat
yourself up yeah well I always had this
I had just put him on this pedestal and
him not calling me back that much
afterwards was like good because I did
get a little mad at him and a little
butt hurt even though I now completely
forgive it and understand it and we're
friends and we're all good but it was
like it was just so like I needed to
like kind of have my heart broken by him
yeah like a final right right like to
just be like okay this is like this is
the way to like tie loose a loose end
maybe you didn't know it was a loose end
but maybe it just was but it needed to
happen because I was like measuring him
up against everyone and it wasn't real
it was like this is like what he was
saying he's like Hello nice to meet you
again like what's going on there's this
song by Sir it's called you can't save
me and there's this line that always
gets to me and I want to know if you
guys agree with this it's um
um wrong place wrong time with the right
one like could someone be truly like the
right one which is all the wrong
circumstances around you or is the right
one going to make it the right time
because now I have my Todd it's like do
you know what I mean it's like and he
has he's like married with kids or
whatever now and like
well I believe that Esther that could
that happen I'm just stuck on that no
guy has ever asked me to take it slow
unless you count asking insisting on
wearing a condom but no one's ever said
wait wait let's let's slow down no yeah
because they have fetishes for a little
bit yeah no but I do think that's such a
beautiful story and I definitely agree
that there's like
right person wrong place wrong time
because how could it not be true but
then maybe but there could be right
people for you in that moment like
like for me after I had like had my
sexual assault and stuff he was like the
right person for me he was like the
perfect thing and I think I like held to
him so tightly because of that and I had
this whole story playing in my head that
I hadn't included him in you know like I
didn't clue and he was like even saying
he was like could you be here like with
me and I'm like no and it's like
so why are you even doing this it's like
it's like I was like chasing this
unrequited part yeah but so okay so if
if she's saying you could be the right
person wrong time wrong place whatever
like he could he could he applies for me
I would say he would be that like he was
the right person but it was the wrong
place at the wrong time it's like you
are destined for stardom and for being a
comedian and pursuing your passion like
sure you could have not you could have
chosen him but you didn't and like you
could have and maybe it would have been
a thing but it's like that wasn't the
right this is the right way you know but
then it's like yeah and it's like
but then it's the right people for you
at that maybe it was the right time you
know it's like it was right because it
got me to what I knew you're saying like
it was it played out perfectly for you I
think everything plays out perfectly
this is what I'm truly afraid of meeting
someone absolutely wonderful right now
like because I'm so just like but you
would be ready then if it would but it
would but maybe it wouldn't be yeah I
agree I'm a little fractured still and
it's like I'm so afraid of like
squandering something so great like
imagine if I'm if imagine if I was just
like this is like an amazing person I
could really foresee a life but I'm like
just I feel like I've regressed a lot
and like maybe I'm not uh ready to be in
this like amazing relationship with
someone amazing like I'm I I want it's
almost like I want to intentionally meet
like shitty people right now but you're
anticipating like a thing that's not you
tell this just sounds like literally a
classic anxiety yeah you have anxiety
because you're worried about the future
and you're educated when I met my wife
uh she was living with her ex-boyfriend
at the time really
and and tell us more tell us more and
then like how did you guys like were you
worried that maybe like whoa like this
is too soon like does she need time to
heal from this relationship like am I a
rebound didn't think any of that should
we just clicked and that's it took a
chance and we we clicked and that's it
but immediately that's like oh wow like
living with an ex-boyfriend where do I
fit in and who are you who are you but I
loved who she was and got kept seeing
her kept talking to her did you have any
resentments down the road like in
regards to like wait like it must have
been shaky upfront like it wasn't at all
that's because you guys it was it wasn't
at all but it like at all
there wasn't at all that's that's the
crazy thing is that you think oh man
you're this is the wrong time for you I
was living New York she was in San Diego
what you know it was you know it just
didn't it didn't measure up at all but
then it but then it did because we had
an intense connection and that's it
could it could be that way
wow okay that's hopeful because when I'm
in therapy
um what I'm the the theme of it is
always you need to be alone you need to
feel good in yourself alone without
anything else like in informing your
mental state but sometimes that doesn't
happen sometimes also I thought the same
thing after my last breakup before right
before I met Dave I shook Dave into
being with me I literally remember
thinking like oh my God okay like this
is it this is my time like I need to be
single for a long time like I've been
dating these
people who are not good choices for me
right now and
literally within a month I met Dave it's
like you know
I thought the same I just control over
yeah I had the same thoughts and
anxieties that you're having now so that
to me makes it seem like oh these are
Universal things you're feeling yeah you
know yeah you're not you guys aren't
like worried that like sometimes I worry
that I've just always been in
relationships that I've never really
been single for more than like eight
months yeah but okay so I think the last
six months the end of your relationship
with Bobby is very similar to like how
like the last few like five years of my
relationship have been where it's like
you've been together so long that like
you're able to like build your own life
even though you're still with your
partner like I have a very separate
fulfilled life without Dave and so like
that's just a concern that doesn't isn't
worth paying attention to I think yeah
does that make sense yeah like haven't
you you've been with Bobby but you've
also
haven't you been independent throughout
that as well I have been but I feel like
so much of my identity because we work
together we built yeah together is very
tied
you know still Tethered to him
um I think um I'm I'm terrified that
maybe I don't know how to be alone
because I've always just been in
relationships that I've convinced myself
now that I'm like no no no like you need
to know what it's truly like to be alone
you do or you don't yeah yeah you do or
you don't it's like when things change
like things change like that you can
change like that things around you can
change like that it's like there's no
like there's no point in like predicting
a future it's like there's just no point
that's literally so fast and you're
stealing and you are alone right now and
you're stealing that moment for from
yourself worrying about yeah I'm like
pushing everything away and sometimes I
see these openings of like this person's
incredible but I'm like ah then I'll
like almost like invalidate my own
feelings about it and then then say
something along the line so yeah I'll
probably just [ __ ] them or something
like that well why don't you just be
curious the way you said you're right
you're right but I think that I need to
be curious with myself rather than be so
like judging like I think you need to do
mushrooms I think I do oh my God we
could do mushrooms I felt so like after
doing mushrooms and acid like I felt
like
I really had gotten like very
self-conscious again I'd gone into like
old habits of really being
self-conscious about like what other
people think of me and all that stuff
and then I was just like what is the
[ __ ] point of that it's such a waste
of time and you're just like robbing
yourself and the people that really [ __ ]
with you
of just
being carefree and just doing what you
want and just being your own thing
another thing that's been helping me
lately is like
applying to kind of anxiety stuff is oh
Esther like you just have to think about
the day in front of you like I really
try it's not easy I'm always like even
while we're sitting here like oh my God
Monday I have to do this but like I try
really hard to go to that place where
I'm like it's just about today I just
just what am I what's today what's right
now because like Annie said so
accurately everything can change and I'm
the kind of person we're like dude I if
I taste a meal if I try a new drink and
I like it I'm like okay I need to order
five cases of it because I'm gonna drink
it every day but I'm obsessed with it
and then it's like well in three days
you're gonna be sick of it so why did I
plan for kneading it like didn't you buy
like 30 berries boot camp classes that's
a hundred and they would not exchange
them for Smoothie points and it was a
waste of money but like that's a that is
exactly a habit of mine like if I like
something I have to like cling to it so
tightly and like have it it's like
addiction mindset or whatever but I
think that just applies to like
everything's gonna change you're gonna
be different tomorrow yeah and
everything tastes more delicious and
scarcity it's like I learned that from
when I bought like like three pounds of
seaweed salad from Costco
or those seaweed those seaweed like the
Carlos's main source of of calories like
those are like I ate so many of those
one time that I I had to take like 10
years off from them
dude that's what I did with like songs
when you listen to a song over yeah wait
I made myself allergic to spinach
because I ate it three times a day every
day spinach I can't have chai tea I had
chai tea when I just first discovered
chai tea the year I moved to LA I had it
every day I bought chai tea lotion chai
tea perfume and now I I'm still off of
it somebody didn't see Hassan Menage as
special it's just chai chai means tea oh
he's like you guys are saying TT that's
like when you say ahi tuna it's just Ahi
oh [ __ ] I did not know that yeah Ahi is
just means tuna no educational comedy
special Carlos get a sushi he gets to
put sugar fish no you all had enough
food for the weekend he's going very
y'all to us today he's been yelling us
all day
he's watching Texas stuff oh he's
watching football on the job watching
football he's been watching football
he's either throwing stuff at us yelling
oh that's why he's in a bed I've had a
headache this whole time I've been
hungry for most of it until I ate and
I've been watching football and there
were no beers when I kept checking oh my
God he's an alcoholic egg I need drugs
to be around your ass her ass just her
ass I know because it gets him horny
I genuinely think this is the new look
for you oh my God I do I love being like
it's a hardware chic
I love masculine that's good because
it's so little yeah it's so weird you
got like actually hot wait Carlos is
attracted to me in the vest
no it ruins your friendship so many
twists and turns does it feel like a
lesbian Vibe cool but I'm so glad you're
not one of those girls that's like oh
I'm gay all of a sudden she is
exactly what she is I don't buy it she's
a pick-me lesbian yeah there you go
I am
whatever I want to be you guys yeah it's
time to go home yeah I miss my spot I
wanna go home we need to go yeah this is
not Pete
um this is happening on your watch Pete
how did you let this happen it's all
good was this a good episode we got so
serious or so cute because Esther fate
got mad at me
it's a joke
so I think something is in the air well
I thought we could do another episode
you know what I did put something they
are sorry
it worked
this is weird are you feeling feelings
no it's like why do you guys don't get
feelings
say it like I'm like doing it
your mannerisms it doesn't do that
it did
crazy everyone's [ __ ] Delirious
okay that episode cause is
Schindler's List no
slugs thank you so much we've been
through like heartbreak Holocaust there
were tears
violence violence we were literally had
a drive by salt slugs thank you so much
you are so messed up mentally if you
like this and thank you for that we love
you we are connected we are all the same
we are all [ __ ] flawed in the [ __ ]
road yes we will see you guys see you
next week for an all-new we're gonna get
this [ __ ] to go on the road with us too
thank you
foreign
[Music]